we've made the heading of congruence now
and because we've been doing commerce
for a little while you probably have
been well-trained enough excuse me
there's a particular kind of shape that
you think of when you hear the word
congruence what kind of shape is that
triangles very good it's worth
remembering that you can prove any
shapes are congruent congruence is an
idea that's much bigger than just
triangles in fact it's much bigger than
just shapes we've looked at like
identities in a I can chicken AMA tree
and quadratic functions and all those
are a kind of congruence you're just
talking about two things and they are
exactly identical in every single way
except for say how do you look at them
so they're slightly rearranged like
shapes are reflected or rotated or a
piece of algebra is just slightly
manipulated so it's got different parts
that are focused on but it's still the
same thing right so congruence we use
this symbol here 1 2 3 so it's like it's
not just equal they're really really
equal and there are four tests for tests
that you know of to prove that two
triangles are congruent can you remember
what the four tests are okay so the one
that we tend to remember first is side
side side in other words pair of
triangles right and in fact maybe you
want to draw this off on the beside this
with me pair triangles like this and
this and what they share is three pairs
of corresponding sides that are equal
and that's what the estates right so
something like this
cool so that's what's inside looks like
give me another proof for congruent
someone else sort of zone so you said
again angle-angle-side excellent
angle-angle-side so how would I draw
this what would this look like I can
actually draw the same triangles but I'm
going to label some different things
angle angle sight remember their
corresponding right they're
corresponding so I suppose I could say
let's call this alpha let's call this
beer based on the way that I've drawn
them where would you put Alfred Bader on
the other triangle alpha would go bottom
right hand corner just go down here and
beat it would be yes I'll bizarre excuse
me
so I've got my angle angle by the way
before we move on and put on a side you
can see here that if you've got two
angles being that it's a triangle that
kind of implies that you have a third
angle right you don't need to find a
third angle because once you've got two
that's enough there's a lot of fun is
but you might as well indicate sort of
in an implied way
yeah those obviously are equal as well
so really you have equiangular triangles
and then in this in addition to that you
have side now remember this word that I
say said before they're corresponding or
matching is another way you might have
seen before
this is really important so you can't
just have the side anyway you like it
has to actually match up so let's say
I'll just go over here okay so there are
corresponding happy times okay but if
it's say this side over here
that's beside beta and this side here
between a forbidden it's not the same
hmm you gotta be careful okay make sure
you line up all of your features
properly and this is why when we talk
about triangles we often get you to be
purposeful about naming the coordinates
the vertices in the same order so for
example this is a b c
and let's give this a random M and P and
F okay if I say triangle ABC what would
be the appropriate owner for the other
letters I've deliberately given you
non-alphabetical answers it just
completely where you do SNP because
you're sort of going I have given them
to Union opposite orientations reflected
over so that makes it a little bit
easier okay happy times 1 test 2 test
give me another one i Jeff RHS this is
the hipster of our the congruence tests
it's the one that almost no one ever
uses we'll come back to why that is in a
second what do the only engineer stand
for R stands for right angled so it only
works with right-angled triangles
there's your first reason why it's not
very common on H stands for hypotenuse
and F stands for a type right took how
we going to draw this hmm I guess we're
gonna have to draw this a little bit
differently since it's these guys aren't
well they might be right at your
trailers but no so it's for the right
angle there so you're going to need the
hypotenuse which is this guy over here
and then you're going to need some other
side right so it doesn't matter which
one I guess we'll go with this one for
them ok so what's it going to look like
let's draw this differently again let's
say it's rotated around not just simply
reflective so where am I going to have
the corresponding sides have a look
got the are where's the H the opposite
the right angle so it's going that guy
and this one here is going to be the
longer of the shorter sides the longer
of the shorter side okay that make sense
okay now I said this is this is the
hipster of congruence press have a look
at it right now why do you think almost
no one ever uses this yes Lee well very
frequently you have non right angle
triangles so that immediately wipes out
a whole bunch of triangles right so a
big deal but secondly if they are right
angled if they are right angled and look
you've got two sides
in a right-angled triangle does that not
mean it's very easy to work out what the
third side is like that and then you can
just go for the other reason you already
know okay but nonetheless that's
actually the reason why this works so
there's one there's one last test the
special air service
yeah side-angle-side so it's important
that that a is in the middle because
again the position matters why does it
matter that it's in the middle what does
that mean okay good and that's worth
labeling we included angle so I'm going
to use this or we should draw it first
as well let's draw this guy's so I'll go
back to the original triangles I had if
I'm going to go for side angle side
let's say well if I had these two like I
had before then of course by included
angle we mean the angle that it's formed
by those two sides that you just chose
them so be something like this okay so
these two would be equal using or these
two be congruent using this proof now
this is one of the really good
opportunities to connect this to another
piece of knowledge that you know you got
a pair of triangles right and you want
to find so not a pair of triangles if
you have a triangle something like this
and you know an angle let's call this ah
what's that look like it looks like just
more than ninety degrees let's call it
ninety four and you know a side and you
know another side when you look at
something like this right if you wanted
to find out some information about the
angles in here right let's suppose I
said that was ninety four so maybe this
is something like forty seven okay and
now suppose you don't know this piece of
information if I wanted to find an angle
like this right I are we'd sort of made
up what it was but suppose you didn't
know now you were tasked with finding
out what could you do
if you do yep okay if you quite catch
that
right you can use the sign rule in this
triangle right because you can match up
this guy with this one then you can
match up this guy with this one that's
not the angle you want over there but
you can use it to find the angle that
you do want and that looks good right
but you know in cases like these you
have to be careful with the same right
this animal has baked into it a problem
to remember what the problem was
there's there's ambiguity in the same
rule right you might get some angle out
of this you could go ahead you can
crunch the numbers use your calculator
to shift sign and there you get
something okay if the answer you got was
say 60 degrees there would be another
possible size what would the possible
size be 60 would go with 120 its
supplement okay now here is why here is
why when I took away this angle in here
right and I said okay now you only know
about this one all of a sudden this is
actually not the only triangle that you
could be imagining which has all of
these measurements right because you no
longer have side angle side you've got
the angle off in some funny spot okay I
can draw another triangle and so can you
which has these same measurements and
this same angle but it's a whole
different triangle it's not congruent
because you don't have side angle side
the angles in the wrong spot okay seeing
is you can draw a whole different
triangle that's where this other mystery
angle comes from your ambiguous case
okay so this is your other reason why I
think when we went back to the ended use
case I argued it from the graph do you
remember that I said when you're proving
or when you're finding rather the size
of the angle the calculator will hand
you back the acute angle but there's
another angle which has exactly the same
sign and that can be a plausible result
but another way of thinking about it is
if you do not have side angle side so go
back and have a look if you still have
it in your book when we were doing
earlier in the year when we're doing
trig and we're just practicing the sine
rule have a look at the positions of the
angles and that's when you're there's
uncertainty okay size outside angle
angle v RHS SAS
for proof okay before I get you guys
started I want you to remember it's
really nice and neat actually every
single congruence proof always has one
two three four five lines five lines are
maybe a few off on the side do you
remember what the five lines are really
you've done them a lot I'll give you a
clue the first line starts with the word
in okay so you're going to name some
triangles right for instance you might
name these guys in triangle ABC and
triangle F and P okay this your first
line there you have three lines that are
all going to be very similar to each
other in character three lines because
they go to correspond to these three
properties right so I guess the way you
can structure it is reason one reason to
these in three okay and they're just
going to correspond to the three
features whichever appropriate what's
the fifth and final line okay it's just
your conclusion right
you'd say therefore these two things are
congruent and you are almost done
there's only one last piece of in point
information namely which of the tests
have you appealed to okay just to make
it easy for you I think it's nice to try
and put your reasons in an order so that
you're like oh it's easy to read off
some people even write the reasons in
order like this to make it just one step
easier for you one less thing to think
about when you going through it finally
I did say that they can be sometimes a
little more than five lines what if
something isn't obviously just stated
right there if you can just see it you
need to do some deductive reasoning you
can either put it up here just do all of
that reasoning up front and then if you
want to appeal to that reasoning you say
proven above or there's no reason why
you can't stick it in here or here
wherever it needs to appear just so long
as you don't get lost in the woods so I
tend to just my preference is to do it
like this so that when I'm going through
this I know exactly on doing one two
three
samih
but if you don't remember to do that and
you're like oh no there's an extra thing
I need to do it's fine to put in here
just so long as you have your entire
structure there